when they say brooms up that's when you
go we're gonna run straight down and
Danny over there she's gonna strap that
ball back what's it called queef waffle
this is called ultimate bucket list
[Applause]
we're all gonna choose items from our
bucket list to determine what belongs on
the ultimate bucket list as in the list
of things that everyone should try to do
everyone you're probably wondering why
we look so sporty because today's
episode is we're not competitive I'm
competitive I'm competitive I'm very
competitive today we're here with Dan
Jasmine what do you like magic what
don't you like sports I'm jasmine what
do you like winning for done you like
losing Oh
- tell me on your bucket list that might
be sporting I have chosen to War
wrestling are you worried you guys don't
look excited well there's a law go
through my head first of all is like
physique secondly looks pretty and then
third clothing serious alarm bells going
off about the whole
I'm concerned about the nappy the the
diaper thing
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is Andrew fry and so we're here
at a sumo dojo we're gonna practice
sooner today that's okay I can see
you're pumped up yeah hopefully in a
short period of time you can learn a lot
of skill and we may have surprise for
you at the very end
surprise oh yeah do it to be like scared
of this surprise you should be scared
the lordís okay joke
I'm actually the multi-time the US
National Champion so you don't have to
be big so there's there's hope for all
of you except for Dad yes thank you
I enjoy academic pursuits I've never
gotten in a fight in my life so yeah I
don't think I'm gonna be very good at
this what are the rules of sumo wrestle
you want to either push your opponent
out of the ring or knock your opponent
down so that any part of the body
besides the soles of the feet touches so
if the knee goes down you lose you want
to either push your opponent down or out
and that's about it it's in two because
it's like a physical sport but you don't
take a punch it's like strength which
isn't my strength when we talk quickly
about the attire so you're first here
Dan hold it there now spin where we
would say a sumo belt or a loincloth
the Japanese word is mawashi you could
wear them washing over your shorts or
tights or whatever
don't feel like I would scare anyone so
wants to see me in a dark alley I don't
well they probably would run just
because they see me dressed like this so
we'll do an abbreviated version of a
practice we're gonna do some of the
basic warmups do some of the basic
movements
yeah we'll do some light sparring light
pouring exactly so I'm gonna get in the
ring you know I was okay with the
warm-ups I think I'm gonna be all right
I don't like it missed a shot I think I
can pull my own I just have to be strong
stay on my feet because I gotta prove
that I can be a sumo wrestle because I
gotta prove that I can do sumo wrestler
I didn't even know girls could do sumo
wrestling Here I am
[Music]
we have a really special surprise today
we're gonna bring out someone who spent
most of his life
intro sumo let's meet my friend kid okay
okay
now both points on what he done his name
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sumo wrestling check who knew we
consumer my one aids baseball baseball I
know you guys grew up with it as a
foreigner I didn't I've never thrown a
ball never swung a bat is so bad at
baseball growing up I will have baseball
and never I was really bad I want a home
run away oh there it is you're making me
want to run away I was I am petrified me
too
just take a swing at it okay yeah but I
don't want to be like you and strike out
Jasmine do you have any to pitch
unexpected that was quite slide
or should I say quite slide
I grew up seeing baseball movies but
they don't play baseball in England hi
I'm Dom Guerrero a head groundskeeper
for the Inland Empire sixty-six errs do
we look the paw you guys definitely look
the part especially you with their shirt
tucked in taking this seriously today
I'll be teaching you guys how to hit how
to set yourself up set your bat here and
you're gonna want to set up like this
let me see a pitch you're gonna step
pivot then seems very out this comes out
so how fast are these balls coming at us
I'll try to sneak a few by in there if
my eight-year-old self could see me now
I'd be surprised Jasmine said that they
throw it at your head so let's get to it
yeah let's do it
they're just really cool baseball
players that doesn't come naturally to
English people let's play ball so how
they say it oh they do okay we're gonna
play ball
[Music]
keep your eye on the ball straight in my
head this is awesome this is really fun
[Music]
[Music]
all right let's do this
I just want to hit it really I just want
to hit the ball once I hope I hope I can
do that still nervous but this is my
moment this is my time
[Music]
by the ball
it might eat yourself could see me now
it's exhilarating or disposed allright
totally underestimated you I
underestimated you too though oh okay
what is on your list you've been very
smug about this it's a little
unconventional but you've got to keep an
open mind do you promise to keep an open
mind so we are going to play Quidditch
wait how you'll see what I mean if you
don't know what Quidditch is like get
ready to have your world rocked a game
from Harry Potter where you fly around
in a broom you try and store up all of
these hoops and you have to catch the
Golden Snitch to win the game I don't
get how it's gonna work we fly you
promised of an open mind I didn't
promise anything I'm not ready Jasmine
I'm worried she's gonna make fun out of
everyone okay I'm crying already
I think that she's going to just be
mocking me mercilessly I'm gonna take
this quite seriously it's interesting
it's I brought a little Gryffindor touch
of my own representing there's some
interesting characters well one of them
was speaking Parseltongue oh I'm a
Christian though I was in the movie I
mean at the end of the day I was in
Gryffindor House I've got to represent
I'm Lindsey Simpson I'm the captain of
the Lost Boys Quidditch Club we're here
in North Hollywood California and about
to play Quidditch game
this is on my bucket list but like how
does it work here
we usually explain it as its rugby needs
ultimate frisbee meets dodgeball all of
those things are physical this is a
full-contact sport
ACL tears concussions broken bones don't
be scared we use PVC pipes with Petersen
brooms it stays between your legs at all
times in the movie the snitch is flying
ran they chase it how does the snitch
work when you're on the ground so we're
gonna have somebody wearing this really
glorious pair of yellow shorts on the
back is the snitch tail so each team has
a seeker I want to be the seeker it's my
it's my decision right it's my bucket
list I get to choose what I want to do
and it's their goal to catch the snitch
tail and that earns them 30 points and
[Music]
I'm seeker let's do this so when they
say brooms up that's when you go we're
gonna run straight down and Danny over
there she's gonna rock that ball back
what's it called a queef
Quaffle Dan's really into it as well
he's found his calling they are going
down he'll be here every night now once
a week for three hours down will be
[Music]
[Music]
he was unbelievable but accuracy in her
power I didn't have a chance it's a very
complicated sport so much going on
Jasmin's still have that banquet like
two hours big respect to Harry Potter
who did this in the sky this game is all
running it is insane the yellow ball
that's hanging off the guys but I gotta
grab it I gonna win this game till 1:00
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
injury check I got bruised by a baseball
you got bruised by sumo wrestler what
happened to you my hand hurts from
batting that's it we need to decide what
belongs on the ultimate bucket list just
because of how terrible I was at
baseball as a kid like I never made
contact with the ball before Oh a hot
baseball is cool can we not talk about
that mascot I want to talk about Bernie
the sumo wrestling even getting wrecked
by that guy she was amazing
Quidditch I left way too soon never
laughs at Quidditch that being said I
feel like sumo wrestling is a one in a
lifetime experience you can't top it for
the sake of the ultimate bucket list
does sumo sumo sumo sumo sumo
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]